ok here we go today this is our first
day chatting with anybody since the end
of our IndieGoGo goodbye promise
campaign we have the pleasure of
speaking with not only a filmmaker a
cowboy and he's always one who seems to
you know in the last several years when
we were pushing Lucas mcnellie's year
without a rent when we were pushing Jack
marchetti's campaign just recently his
former kind campaign and now recently
you know our our own campaign if this is
a guy that sort of comes out it's part
of the Calvary you can find him on
Twitter Kevin Fox films um he has his
own experience with distributing his own
work he does niche films cowboy films
and we're gonna go back and forth and
sort of um you know we're gonna learn
from what we've done you know get his
take on it and learn from what he's done
Kevin but welcome aboard here today
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
absolute pleasure oh nice nice meeting
you in Google person you know it's like
this total it's a total turn oh my gosh
there's your cat I was just watching
James Cooper's a interview with you guys
that you posted last week in about I
don't know i think it was 27 40 or
something in the cat made an appearance
that I was like there's yeah try to kiss
him when you saw you know are you my
crown fun you okay yeah you know that
this is this is a new world for us to
take it outside the radio studio knowing
and you know here at home and just in
front of the computer and chat with
people you know Kevin with this
conversation today we wanted to start
with just the the overall impact that
that this goodbye promised indiegogo
campaign had on you um okay the the
campaign itself okay first of all i was
drawn in because you guys twitted me
personally and I think the tweet was hey
where's our cowboy as if i was sleeping
hey you know we need your help here and
i've always considered you guys friends
just like I do many of my twitter
friends in the indie film community on
twitter
um and whenever I can I'm I'm always
there if if I don't know you you don't
have a you know we don't we don't have
this regular conversation going on um
you better make me love your campaign I
better love your film um the films or
like the campaign's that I like to get
involved with on whatever platform
Kickstarter IndieGoGo I know that's a
big debate um I look to be innovative
and you mentioned Lucasfilm and um you
know I jumped on that because that was
absolutely innovative what Lucas was
doing I immediately saw was going to
benefit everybody in the indie film
community um and I had some banner
Twitter's during goodbye promise with
with Lucas I know he's working hard um
inkay I think Karen scolded me well you
know that banner better being good fun
and it absolutely was anybody that
doesn't think that Lucas McNally and and
others but i'll use Lucas as an example
that are trying to explain to us in the
ND community how this is evolving you
know they're giving us sort of a
definition and a case studies of how
it's working but what they're really
doing is if you put that all together
this is how this industry is evolving
and if anybody doesn't date that Lucas
McNally is one of the hardest working
guys in indy community um well you're
fooling yourself and you know you may
not like his gruff attitude but I think
he's a straight shooter in cowboy terms
going back to goodbye promise you guys
said hey I need your help I'm always
there to help so immediately I looked at
the page and I thought okay one buck two
bucks how that how are you guys gonna
make a million dollars in 30 days at one
dollar a two dollar winter that's not
possible and again I was uh watching
your interview last week um here
recently with um James Cooper and I
think his quote was here's
here's a crowdfunding campaign they
can't fail and I think I had the kind of
the same notion but immediately I didn't
understand what the end goal was so
ultimately the historian and
documentarian I am I dig a little deeper
and I click some tabs and kind of figure
out that hey you know that this you can
watch this film it's on YouTube tada you
know you don't have to pay for this you
know um but it didn't seem right I'm a
big advocate of not bootlegging software
or you know that sort of thing I've been
an artist a long time and you know when
people steal work to make other work or
whatever that kind of irks me um didn't
seem right to just click on the YouTube
and and do it I knew people would so I
threw in I thought more than my share um
and my hopes was in that that not only
my contribution could boost some ratings
but that other people who couldn't
afford it or whatever could watch this
film um so initially I jumped in because
you guys are friends of mine and that's
ultimately what crowdfunding is about
you go and you get your friends and your
family and whoever else you know is
capable of helping you it took me a
couple of days to actually sit down and
watch goodbye promise I you know I'm
involved in my own production right now
I'm i was on a deadline with a client
and some other things but um after
finally saying knuckle endowed and
saying I got to see this film my whole
perspective kind of changed because you
know good goodbye promise is uh not a
film about Hollywood certainly it's a
film about um having a goal and having a
dream and setting limitations and being
realistic and there were particular
scenes in that film that affected me um
um you know personally I don't live in
Hollywood don't care to don't aspire to
have the Holly
dream it's why I don't live there I
don't want to be rich I don't want to be
famous um you know but then there were
scenes there that made me focus on what
i'm doing and what i'm trying to attempt
and it had me reassessing where I'm at
and where I plan to be in that seven
years um the campaign itself and after
you know especially after you guys
started posting these sort of rules of
engagement um became very very clear on
what you were doing and to me the way
that you release it and again I know
there's this big debate whether you you
know use Kickstarter for this and India
go go for that or you know whatever and
I've never crowdfunded I've never raised
I'm fortunate enough that I don't have
to do that I have a nonprofit that funds
most of my pictures so um you know there
may come a time when I have to do that
so trust me i'm studying the case matter
but what what i saw you guys doing is
opening a whole new door and i think i
mentioned to you what you're doing seems
to me on the the crowdfunding um
platform or engagement what the audience
is going from the pitch to production to
the pitch production and play and i
found that to be absolutely fascinating
how better to engage your audience from
help me make this film this is what my
films about i hope you like it helped me
make this film to this is where we're at
in production here's some clips to show
you about your investment to hey here's
your movie and I think that's what you
guys did here um I know you use two
different platforms from you know start
to finish but you ended up on India go
go and you ended up showing at least me
I can't speak for everybody but at least
me I think you showed on the rest of us
out here that a lot of things are
possible and we're not going to stop as
independent filmmakers we're going to
continue to evolve this you can't stop
us
and you're going to have to catch up to
us when it seemed like not long ago when
these platforms emerged we were trying
to catch up with them so instantly you
guys have kind of pulled this reversal
and it's um now it seems like once again
the indie film community has the upper
hand and I just love that concept that's
cool want to take it from there um you
know I'll continue I'll get the I you
know I'm just I'm listening iiiii really
wow you know I just just from your
assessment there at Kevin we can see
that we made a great decision in terms
of we want to talk to you know post
campaign um you know I that was um that
you really hit on some things there you
know you know you know that's not too
thing sometimes with what we're doing is
we're in the middle of it and we can
gain so much from just these additional
perspectives that we're trying to gather
you know we're trying to gather these
case studies and we're trying to figure
this out we're trying to push it into
that next thing and one thing you hit
about you know there at the end there is
I guess the whole thing and you know
that's why we wanted to do this I mean
it wasn't easy to say okay we're going
to bypass film festivals we're gonna you
know sort of bypass the whole system
because it there's a lot of
gratification that comes with that you
know when you start getting accepted in
the film festivals and maybe you start
winning you some awards and it really
sort of you know makes you feel better
as a filmmaker um but for us you know it
was this more just we just wanted to
just get it as many people as whatever
that number was going to be we just want
to start getting it in front of people
and and that and it was what there were
tough questions we had to ask in terms
of what's currently available that we
could use that could be exciting as a
way to release this film tournament and
and as we're looking at crowdfunding and
as we went back and forth from first
first kick side we were looking at and
then and then we looked at IndieGoGo and
we just felt that combination of like
look this platform exist you know
YouTube already exists and sort of
marrying these platforms and and still
like you're saying keeping that
independent spirit as a way instead of
going one film festival at a time to you
know because we just had conversations
for me just yesterday with another actor
and he's like so how about this film but
how about this one vessel and how about
this don't bust won't you know what
about this one and and it's tough cuz
this is like yes that they come with
their advantages and yes we'd love to do
that but at the same time you know here
we have an opportunity where it's just
like this does one big film vessel from
you know we were able to reach people in
19 or 20 different countries and 30 days
so if you look at what we've done you
say wow that was just their first film
festival you know this is there's so
many ways to look at this so far I like
to which you said Kevin about is sort of
a three-fold process first crowdfunding
to make the film and then second
involving them saying here's words
become your investment and showing you
know sort of the progress and then the
third here's your movie i like that i
mean that's good i mean i have to say i
was initially resistant to the idea and
I was especially scared of the the
million-dollar mark um but but i think
you know i know with a lot of days ideas
i might be to resist to him at first and
then we kind of say alright well let's
just try it you know and and it ends up
working out so um i'm happy for the
feedback that you're giving us because
it is hard to see how people perceive it
you know we're kind of in this bubble
just add our computers putting stuff out
there and in its it's just kind of I
don't it's just hard to see if you lie
cyl ate a little bit and so it's thank
you I appreciate that you know summing
it up I like that you know what no
worries and change feels weird you know
I mean to and that's what you guys did
you you have koultimate Lee flip-flopped
hopefully what the indie film community
is now possibly capable of doing but I
want to pose a question to you guys as
far as film festivals going into a film
festival and taking a film into a film
festival what comes first the chicken or
the egg I personally believe you're more
likely get to get accepted in a film
festival if because it's the butts in
seats you know ultimate deal if you can
come in with your own laurels so you
know you you're trying to get their
laurels at
film festival but if you come in with
your own the ones you've already
accomplished you're more likely to be
accepted now that's just my opinion and
not necessarily be the truth but I think
that's what you guys have done here you
have shown I'm not what were the number
600 in something actual page views and
then if you look at the youtube I mean
it's it's a thousand something and then
20 countries it's like so now if you
take this thing to a film festival you
can say hey film festival programmer
here's your audience you know and enter
here I guarantee if you accept my film
I'll put butts in seats which is a
tactic that i have used to get into film
festivals now i haven't done a lot of
competition in film festivals but i love
the film festival atmosphere i love
getting together with people and
discussing like we are now and and
exploring new ideas and finding out what
people are doing so there's that
festival atmosphere that i think is
important in the indie community um but
i think what you guys are doing now is
um coming into if you choose to film
festival coming in and saying look at
these numbers and there's no denying
that you know I mean how innovative is
that because now you're reaching out to
an audience who wasn't involved in the
campaign I may not necessarily even have
a clue about India go go or how to
crowdfunder what the indie film
community is doing they just bought a
ticket to a film festival in some potok
little town that they live in and they
want to be a part of it but now you're
exposing them to a whole process that is
available to film makers and now you
guys because you're able to go to these
film festivals and say this is how we
did it and this is how you can help fund
other indie films now you're dragging
them hopefully not kicking and screaming
but your drag helping to drag them into
this entire indica film community and
you guys both know from the twitter feed
there's a lot of people that are
involved in the indie community they're
not necessarily filmmakers and we need
more of that we can't be pitching you
know fund my film fund my film fund my
film to filmmakers who are trying to
fund their own
film yeah we can't do that wait we have
to rely on people like Petra and movie
Angeles you know you know patty fantage
all those other you know some of these
other people that you know throw money
at these films um because um because
they believe in what we're doing yeah I
think that's a key point is how do you
get beyond your own sphere of influence
and I think that is really hard and you
know I think it was great that we were
able to sort of you know spread it
beyond that and 90 that's the tough part
um is getting beyond that those family
friends and also to people that are your
peers in the industry I think I'm
slightly to the left about film
festivals i know dave has a very
definite opinion on them for me I don't
know if I really want that for us but I
know for some people who don't have a
platform you know we spent three years
building a radio show which we had to
pay to do so there's money involved and
so I know a lot of people don't have
that time or luxury whatever to do that
and therefore I think festivals might be
a necessary step maybe not Sundance or
one of these bigger ones that most
people won't get into but I think some
of the smaller ones it is I don't want
to call it a necessary evil because it's
not evil but you know I'm saying it's
that it might be something that people
would have to do whereas we were
fortunate enough to have a website and a
radio show that had some views so you
know but yeah even even be honest till
it was hard to get beyond our little
niche of whatever followers we have okay
and to expand on your point there Kevin
not me so far we've we've been contacted
by three film festival since we launched
the campaign one film fest the wise
invited this up to speak and in this one
I don't even think as a narrative film
festival I think this one is a
documentary film festival and then we've
had two other festivals that have
contacted us and we've we've sent them
the link to the film so it's it's hard
to say we still don't know what would
happen from that we don't know if more
film festivals going to contact us but
you know we I think we sort of share
your opinion that you know especially
for these smaller independent films you
know show a show that you're
film has some clout show that people
were interested in your film show it
show some of the feedback and then and
then maybe that'll open up some new
doors I I don't know still even even
even now if we're going to go out of our
way to submit to a lot of film vessels
we have some other plans determine what
we like to do with the film and so but
but if they contact us a hey just can
you just can we just see a screener can
you know and can we see the film
wherever well happily share it and and
if they sort of invite us along and say
look we want to screen the film we like
to get you guys here and talk about what
you guys doing you know we're totally up
for that you know and and and I you know
we can see that being away you know to
maybe put some of the power back in
independent filmmakers for us to bring
our films for us to bring our stories
and for whatever audience that we've
built up to kind of bring that and
promote and share it and we think that
that's eventually where things will be
headed you know we believe in sort of
growing you know as much as you can
online and then you sort of take that
offline and share in the experience we
feel film festivals can play that role
on even more so moving forward sure you
know um there's you bring more clout to
this just being David and Karen and film
courage with this film than anything
else and what I what I don't think now
some of my background is in in concert
production and concert production
management so I understand the other
side of you know the film festival the
organization side of the film festival
and I know there's some you know some
people in the film community indie film
community that say oh we shouldn't
charge and all of that stuff but there's
expenses involved and I mean that's a
fact whether you agree with that or not
that's your opinion but I happen to know
the facts about the other side um and um
you know in order for those film
festival is to be sustainable i'm also
really heavily involved in in my own
small town community and you guys know
if you watch without a box you know you
see these mom-and-pop film festivals
starting up in in every town across USA
you know
um and they're desperately trying to
find some way in this you know economic
mess that we're all dealing with
nationwide in int or turn it into not
only read about revitalize economy in
their own community but to bring their
communities together and I think it's a
wonderful concept not that it's
practical concept for some communities
but it's a wonderful concept for these
small communities to want to rally
around film and independent film now
fortunately for us as independent
filmmakers usually they can't afford big
Hollywood to come to their small town so
we get showcased over you know some some
bigger names um often they'll bring
talent in um uh to you know to boost
things um but again but again I think
you guys going in with your clout um you
have a bigger pool and I don't want to
put it on you that you have a
responsibility but you've almost taken
this responsibility as being sort of um
what we what I see we especially in the
Twitter community rally around film
courage and the idea of what film
courage is all about to when you go to
these say if you choose to go to these
things to be representing the rest of
the indie film community and that's what
I sort of mean by sort of you know
breaking down this door for the rest of
us if you get into a film festival I
think it's because they said wow here's
a completely you know dyi no budget not
even micro budget but no budget you know
film done in a very professional way um
and self distributed in order to say hey
Here I am watch me and now you're having
film festivals court you you know I
think that's a wonderful concept so if I
had to throw advice at you I would say
don't rule it out but be very selective
on what film festivals you choose it's
what I do I mean with my own genre I
can't you know blanket I'm never an
advocate of any film maker to blanket
put out you know I'm gonna send or
whatever
cell phone my without a box um that's
just to me a waste of money but um be
very selective and do your research and
um and I'm not speaking to you guys I
know you do your research i'm speaking
to other filmmakers might be watching
this but do your research and and know
if your film is going to be you know
right for that genre you know Lucas when
he came here he had some time here in
San Francisco and as stay RT and I got I
got to enjoy that guy for three days in
my house and believe me we stayed up to
all hours in the morning and I picked
his brain he picked my brain and I
understand his point of view on film
festivals sure you guys do too um and we
kind of differ a little bit but um you
know one of the things that we um we
agreed upon was absolutely do your
research know who you're talking to you
one of the best advice that Lucas gave
me was have no fear into sending the
program or a festival organizer a
personal message and just flat-out
saying this is my film this is what it's
about isn't right for your festival what
are you gonna program this and I've used
that and I've decided through several
film festivals that yet that guy just
wants my money and he may or may not
choose me and if he does choose me now
he plans to use me as his own clout and
do I want to be put in that position so
you know I want to digress just a little
bit David you mentioned documentary film
festival is courting you how fascinating
is that because as a documentary
filmmaker when I got into goodbye
promise instantly I realized this is
real this is not scripted and of course
I went back to the thing and I realize
oh it's a hundred percent improv and
when I finish the film um and I went on
my facebook page and after the campaign
was over and I told everybody you know
if you haven't seen it this is where you
need to start I went back to all your
Kickstarter videos that you put on
YouTube were you introduced all the
characters telling what goodbye promise
was and that's where I fell in love with
the characters not doing that watching
the movie I went back and saw you as
real people playing these characters as
real
people and telling me what it was all
about and so I find it very interesting
that a documentary film festival is now
courting you because you know now our
week now crossed January with goodbye
promise the 20 pitch you brought those
videos because the thought came to us
that today actually and here we are post
campaign method that maybe we should
have revamped those videos and we could
we could have put those back out during
during this release of the campaign so I
was wondering actually why you didn't do
that yeah you know I guess I guess no I
think not that you didn't have other
stuff to do no I you know it sometimes
we need you know I mean here we are
we're distributing the film but also
we're using a crowdfunding platforms and
sometimes you just come up with a
certain game plan of like ok these are
the kind of things we're going to do
during this release and then you know
you can plan so much you can strategize
so much but once the time is ticking and
the times under way it's just you know
you try to utilize your resources as
best you can you know and so it's kind
of like you're i guess like surfing and
you know once that wave hits and you're
in the wave and you're riding it it's
like you just have to ride the way as
best you can until until it's all done
so sure you have to concentrate on where
your feet are at where the wave is that
and all of that and I in and we clearly
saw you guys doing that I mean on it and
it's refreshing to hear that you know
and I know it's the rule but it's
refreshing to hear that you actually had
a plan and you stop to it and you know
you left those videos out of the plan
but at least you stuck to your plan am I
wrong in that you know as best we could
you know there was there was a lot of
levels that we weren't able to hit you
know we thought initially that we would
be able to track you know i mean frankly
we thought we'd be able to get more
people because if we were only asking
for one dollar we just thought that not
necessarily a higher dollar amount
because we never thought that the
average would end up being close to
eight dollars per person you know we're
thinking okay people were just going to
be contributing a dollar at a time and
we just thought we'd be able to reach
more people especially early on and so
there were a lot of things that
we just never hit that level of
engagement you know we had some things
that we wanted to do in terms of group
reward because and things like that we
wanted to partake but it ended up being
a campaign of just really just on the
lowest level you know from from start to
finish it was really just a level or we
just had to focus on engagement you know
that that was pretty much the campaign
from day one to last day was just
engaging with those who were engaging
with us um well what was the audience
you were attempting to engage was it
Hollywood actors was it you know the the
gym you know general public you were
trying to educate about Hollywood actors
what who who was your target audience um
you know that no Karen I you know we've
been building um you know film courage
for over three years you know and we
felt that this was a movie that that's
spoke to a lot of people that pay
attention to film Kurds you know so with
this initial release we first wanted to
just get as many folks from film courage
on board you know and some some of our
earlier folks that supported on the
Kickstarter campaign so so that was a
big part of our engagement and then sort
of some outer circles you know beyond
that we may we made big attempts to get
into the acting community and reached
out to you know we hit a lot of acting
websites you know we had a hard time
sort of a penetrating some folks there
so I guess the heart of it was as many
people sort of surrounding the
independent film community as we could
because you know there's a lot of it
that that it's an artist story and we so
we went after filmmakers and in terms of
once again reaching some of those outer
levels they kind of staggered and it was
like it was like hitting cement all
around us and so you know and thatthat's
and that's mainly because you know you
need to create enough momentum to
continue to how to roll out that far and
you know it was it was still sort of
centralized too so our immediate
outreach I guess I'm intrigued by
something that you said Kevin and you
said that you're interested in the back
stories of some of the characters to
some of these initial crowdfunding
videos
in terms of the campaign that we just
did what do you think would have been
really great in getting like additional
stories from those same actors or maybe
some of the other actors that we didn't
talk to what would you have liked to
have heard um a very interesting
question Karen um you know dirt during
the pitch process I think and I'll speak
purely as a consumer during the pitch
process I want to hear why I want to
invest in this film but I think what you
guys did with the release of goodbye
promise was different which is why you
know I kind of you know dug up those
those older videos where um you know the
players the actors are talking about the
characters that they played and and what
good bike um when I saw those videos um
it helped me better understand um the
motivation the acting motivation that
went in behind it I mean clearly you saw
in the performances that there was real
dialogue kind of coming across one of my
favorite scenes is fighting about money
in the kitchen um and and and I am
immediately when I saw that and and at
the time knowing that it's it's improv
you know I want as a documentarian and
historian and always wanting to know the
backstory I wonder where that motivation
comes from you know um you know a lot of
your other actors and one of the other
scenes that really really deeply
affected me was the scene on the on the
roof where you know the film director is
telling the actor who the actors
confronting the film director which is
always the case you know why why isn't
the movie done and you know he seems to
have excuse after excuse after excuse
and I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it I'm
going to do it and then finally this
sort of revealing truth comes out you
know that life happens and my life is
more important than this movie in your
career at this point on this roof and
that's what I took away
from that and then is sorta I don't want
to give us foiler but then it sort of
carries on where an even bigger truth is
revealed at the party between the same
characters and and you know mines or
speaked and it's just like this is how I
feel and I you know in its this is what
I'm dealing with and your problems are
insignificant to that um so you know
after seeing that that's why I went back
and dug up those stories I wanted to
know where this motivation you know for
how this came from and again I don't do
narrative um so it's hard for me to
understand this what you actors do I
think I tweeted during the campaign a
John Ford quote you know you can teach
an actor to be a cowboy but you can't
teach a cowboy to be an actor which is
why I do documentary in the documentary
I do I want people to be real and and um
when I saw goodbye promise and then
realized this is the truth there is
there is nothing fabricated here words
that are coming out of their mouths are
true life experiences that's what you
know that's what hooked me you know in
the hole in the whole thing so I hope I
answered your question Kern yeah no I
love it I love it you know also from a
consumer point of view Kevin because we
haven't had of you we you know believe
it or not we just haven't had a lot of
feedback because this is also so new but
I guess right before I get to the
question that was that was part of this
release as well it's like you said we're
sort of we're sort of breaking down new
walls and and and and when you sort of
innovate in this sort of fashion it's
just like you know not only be trying to
release the film we get people to see it
but we're also trying to explain the
process and just have people wrap their
heads around like what we're doing the
fact that here we are proud funding it
at the same time the film's available
and you can see it in this whole thing
you know we feel like you know you know
and we're also doing it on a platform
that's not not exactly built for what
we're looking for and also we're trying
to like do the best we can with a
platform that exists so if if that if
the platform really comes along and if
it evolves and you have like the
hands-on tools that are necessary you
know that might help you reach more
people and be more effective than all
that but from from what
point of view um in terms of using
IndieGoGo and sort of you know you know
going through the payment process and
then going and seeing the film on
YouTube were there any issues there i
mean how seamless was that process for
you you know it's interesting that you
brought that up i actually i think
during the campaign on the last night
actually um you and I had that quick
discussion um IndieGoGo it's all
personal preference i imagine i don't
keep money in it in an amazon account
which is how you pay for you know
kickstarter so i have to go to my you
know ATM card or my credit card and i
actually have to type those numbers in
and you know and throw money and you
know you're an artist I'm an artist I
hope artists are watching this and we're
all broke and we're all broke together
um I set money aside in my paypal
account for the sales of my own film to
support indie film it's something I've
done for a long time um and it's how I
try to throw money back you know to
support what everybody else is doing um
and India Go Go just allowed that to be
super seamless in and easy for me so
that was really just a personal
preference thing um I think I like the
Kickstarter idea because you know amazon
is secure and all of this but you know
to be to be honest and again coming from
the area that i live in where less
people know how to work their email then
even are aware of what amazon is and
having them go through the process of
setting up an account in order to give
the money in and that's a matter of
convenience to you have to have an
amazon account if you don't use amazon
you ain't get no money you know um and
paypal just makes it easy because once
you hit that step you know it's a matter
of inning you're either your credit or
your paypal or you enter a credit card
number or whatever you know that might
happen to be um so again that's personal
preference but i didn't yeah either way
I've done both
but um I just preferred this India Go Go
experience um as just being more
convenient and then and then as a
filmmaker I mean how did you take it you
know in terms of you know the overview
of saying okay like here are another set
of filmmakers and they're using
IndieGoGo as the storefront they're
using YouTube on the back end to watch
the film you know what did you think of
that in terms of like wow this this is
how easy it can be there's no other
middlemen you know and I'm sure you've
seen like the 14 reasons that we
highlighted why would be why we chose
IndieGoGo um you know what it's like
that that immediate instant access to
the film do you have any additional
commentary on that on that part as a
fellow filmmaker in terms of you know
because you had to go through out
deliverables and then all this stuff in
terms of delivering your film you know
DVDs and all this said what did you
think of that part of the process what
you know all of us as artists filmmakers
whatever photographers musicians writers
etc were all affected by this internet
thing and and and everybody says you
know once you put it out there it's it's
free you know kind of deal and i'm not a
big advocate of that because i know how
us as artists are supposed to make money
what i think i would like to see and
when i'm hoping that you guys have sort
of um ignited here is that these
platforms are going to take a good hard
look at what may be some VOD platforms
are using I'm a big advocate of dynamo
player rob mills over there has always
been good to me with my films whenever I
have any questions he jumps right back
in so you know at dynamo video on
Twitter um but um I'd like to see them a
dot something like that that's a little
more secure where it's it's still a
contribution and you know it's like in
your last interview whatever like games
Cooper said and he sees selling his book
which i'm about to buy because it was a
great interview but you know whatever
you want to pay whether it's a buck or
five bucks or twenty bucks and like you
guys found that the average was eight
dollars well that's the price of a move
ticket in my town you know eight bucks
for you know uh you know uh not a
matinee showing but you know an evening
showing um however they want to do it
but it needs to be a little more secure
so that we as filmmakers and producers
of the content have some more security
that people are just not a taking
advantage um I think it's to their
benefit as well as ours um and so I'm
hoping what you guys did well will
ignite them to at least explore and pay
attention to what it seems like now the
indie film community is demanding this
is the way we're going to go you created
it we're going to use it and now you
have to catch up to us again and of
course there'll be a time while they'll
leap frogged us and put out something
new and we'll all scramble around and
write articles and blog posts about how
to use it and and and you know we'll try
to one-up them so you know it's all at
an evolution I guess and do you really
see it that way do you really see it
that that walls have been broken you
know a lot of people look at our efforts
and they'll say I know you said 600 but
you know I at the end of the day I guess
we we had 410 rentals it was over 3,200
dollars you know and in terms of
Hollywood in terms of all the
establishment I mean these are these are
steel numbers but do you feel like we've
paid enough to impact r enough other
artists and filmmakers and musicians and
whatever publishers are they looking at
this and saying you know what this this
is something that I'm going to want to
try well I certainly hope they are we
all know as artists don't makers you
know of musicians whatever we all we all
know that this is the wave of the future
everybody you you watch your content on
the subway um you if you're you're
driving your your wife is you know in
the passenger seat watching a movie or
looking up directions it's how we
communicate um and and that's that's
ultimately what filmmaking is and we'll
use that as an example or whatever you
know like you know Kevin gantz music
that's what he does he communicates you
know I mean that's that's what our
is with it it's the study of
communication um and they're going to
have to catch up to us we're going to
have to catch up to it and there has to
be this marriage there has to be this
cooperation we provide the content they
own the platform we can't create the
content and be the ones creating the
platform you know what I mean if that's
the case we're all going to go back to
sidewalk performance you know like in
the Middle Ages where we just you know
put out our hat and dance and sing for
anybody that'll drop money which is also
Lily the concept of you know what you
guys did hey here's my movie put some
change in my hat you know I hope you
like you put some change in my hat and
I'm sure if you look at your statistics
you've got a few passers-by that just
you know through muddy in your guitar
case kind of deal um I hope that the
rest of the industry um is going to see
this and and begin to demand it because
I think we need it I think there needs
to be multiple platforms I need those I
think those platforms need to be uh have
their own personal preferences um and
again going back to the the IG vs
Kickstarter to be you know it's either
this or it's either that and some are
better than this and some is better than
that um it's really personal preference
um I just think that um you know we as
artists filmmakers um those are trying
to make a living doing this trust work
we're scratching to make a living here
um it's what we need and it gives us um
authority and empowerment in order to
reach our audience and I just think
that's ultimately to sum it up I think
that's what you guys did you you open
this door and you said I'm gonna reach
my audience and whether you like it or
not I'm gonna I'm gonna reach out to my
audience so I like that it really does
go down some empowerment I think you're
really right and it costs nothing for us
to do it this way I think that's the
beauty of it and I have no doubt that
someone else could good do it
with much more many more views and
dollar signs attached to it and I hope
someone does but yeah you're right we
didn't require any kind of gatekeeper
you know all we needed was in D go to go
go to say yes you can you know put this
project on there and prove that other
than that there was no gatekeeper Walt
yeah soon are you feeling and listened
with that let's dive a little bit into
what you're doing Kevin you okay can you
first highlight you know cuz you know
maybe that's how broaden the perspective
on everything can can you first
highlight how many feature films you
know have you made over the years I have
I have only done one feature documentary
I've done seven documentaries total all
in the in the cowboy genre now
understand that I have 25 years in them
in the photography industry um going all
the way back to high school I wanted
desperately to be a writer but I I
couldn't dust I couldn't remember where
the commas go after the quote so I knew
I was I was not going to do that that's
kind of mediocre at math I was lucky
enough to marry a math teacher so I'm
covered there um but I realized
photography was um the visual arts and
photography was a great way for me to
communicate my ideas this is back in the
late 1980s when cameras actually gave
you you know three four functions in
order to create an image and everything
else was left up to you you know
nowadays with Instagram everybody's a
photographer with a you know instagram
and a Facebook page wow you could do
this and we're seeing that in in in
we're seeing it become easier in
filmmaking with DSLR and some automatic
modes and you know those types of things
and cameras have evolved also to make it
easier for people to tell the story so
you just need to be creative and not so
technical well when I started um it was
you know dark room and then I got hired
on at a studio and and I was a gaffer
for a long time all I did was lighting
and lighting diagrams and setup and you
know grip work and all of that before I
was even allowed to touch a shutter you
know um let it kind of evolved from
there um
so it was easy for me to make the
transition to filmmaking when I did make
that transition um it was out of
necessity I have a client and I my art
is in i like to call it I'm in the
communicative arts what I do is I take I
people's ideas so I and I I put them
either in in two dimensional print
graphic design or in photographs and and
I applied them to marketing or things
like that in order to communicate an
idea a lot of times it's to sell a
product or a product or an organization
etc for me filmmaking was a necessity
because I had a client approached me and
said we have this dilemma and we need to
shorten this um unfortunately for them
when they put it in my lap being the
storian and storyteller that I always
wanted to be um their little short you
know a sort of industry industrial video
became this documentary and they said
we'll give you 10 minutes to do you know
to do this story well that turned into
30 minutes and the artist that I am I
pounded my fist on the desk in the
office and I said you're not cutting it
you're not taking it no this is the
story we tell the story from the
beginning to the middle to the end
that's a story you don't you can't cut
this it's too important you can I fought
and I fought finally they let me do it
um and the some nonprofit that that I
work with and have for since 2004 I
think 2005 um and I am so blessed on
that these guys have come to understand
what I do is important to them and allow
me to do what I what I do for them
almost you know free reign I mean they
they give me complete creative control
um we do it just like any other film is
done we have a meeting we make it true
you know we do an outline we make a
treatment we do interviews and then I
begin filming generally speaking with a
screening last night of a film that i'm
working on it's called haulers
which is about the it's about the beef
industry cattle dead ranching industry
but from the cattle hauling perspective
and if you've watched the news we've had
a plant closure in hanford that made
national news and we see so much
negative in ranching and agriculture
those seem to be the ones that pop up on
on YouTube all the time and downed
cattle and you know forklifts and some
other things um that we decided to take
this particular film from a completely
different perspective about how cattle
are handled and it completely opened up
a whole new world to me and I grew up in
agriculture about what these guys to do
we did this screening last night sold
out 640 people it was practically
standing room only and you guys have
been to film festivals you know you know
that feeling you get when your film
starts to run and then everybody gets
engaged and it all gets quiet and then
suddenly the crowd erupts in cheers
that's what happened last night and uh
pretty amazing evening and you know
multiple times during the movie um you
know when you've got 600 people in a
building applauding in the in the middle
of the film where you're going whoa wait
a minute that's supposed to be a comedy
line you know and and they're applauding
and cheering your film it's pretty good
pretty awesome feeling so that's cool
yeah yeah that's really awesome you know
so and so this this haulers didn't know
this is this is a short documentary then
this is a it's it's actually we ended up
its supposed to be short documentary
again I go back to they gave me I the
first cut I gave them was 23 minutes and
they said oh no you can't do that so
they said it's got to be 10 I think I
ended up with 17 that we actually showed
so there's always this negotiation that
goes on um we actually shot ended up
shooting about 16 hours of footage
between the four families um and so I
pretty positive it's going to end up as
a 90-minute feature and it's the first
one of these documentaries that this
particular organization has allowed me
to sort of
skirt some of the politics on that go
along with this industry about
over-regulation about uh whether it be
the trucking industry and environmental
issues as far as you know air pollution
and the cattle industry as far as um you
know some of the regulations there do
they're dealing with and if you walk in
if you watch the news nationwide we're
dealing with the drought a lot of people
don't realize that right now in the beef
industry the cattle herd population is
the lowest it's been since in the 1950s
but the demand for beef as a product is
stable and continues to be so and if you
present those as numbers that's an
economist nightmare you know how is this
thing possibly sustainable a lot of
ranchers in my area are getting out of
the business because the price of beef
is so high this is their opportunity to
make back everything that they they owe
the bank for kind of deal so that is
sort of the perspective I'm trying to
take and it's really just an educational
thing I want people to realize that when
they see these things on YouTube when
they hear about these plant closures the
rancher themselves are very often not to
blame you're seeing the worst of the
very worst and the ranchers that I know
and the producers that I know are
genuinely hard-working people that have
been in they don't a family business and
have four four five six generations so
you know that's ultimately you know what
I do my first feature i'll digress again
here my first feature was a rodeo film
called changing the game on it was about
the camarillo family um who was a team
roping family leo gerald and reg
Camarillo who took team roping and rodeo
as a sport sort of like you guys did
examined all the rules and statistics um
in crowdfunding and and what's going on
there and then they turn that whole
industry on on on its ear and they use
the rules on to their own advantage um
and very often they would show up at
rodeos through the between the 1960
is all the way into the 90s um and they
would show up at rodeos and take first
second third fourth and fifth place and
walk away with everybody's money so if
that whole concept was interesting about
how they manipulated the system in in
order to UM play the game going slightly
off topic here on when you go into these
quote environments whether it's
someone's home or whether it's at the
corporate offices of a plant um what's
your approach how how much you engage
with the quotes subjects or are they do
you really want to get to know the
people first before you turn the camera
on what's your approach you know I um
it's good question Karen um personally I
don't really want to know him much at
all I want to be you want to try really
hard to take a journalistic approach I
don't want to um I don't want to be
their friend because I might have to ask
him some hard questions but
unfortunately at the same time in the
genre that I work with and what is being
put out there um people are not often
very trusting so first I have to
convince them that I'm not that sort of
wacko environmentalist guy that's just
gonna sneak on your property and I'm
waiting for you to you know abuse and
animal so that I can put it on YouTube
that I'm not that guy so it's it it's
this sort of when I meet somebody new
unless I'm personally introduced by
someone who can vouch for me kind of
deal sometimes it's tough um you know
fortunately I've been doing this a long
time and I've been working with this
organization and in my area I I have a
reputation for being an advocate in
agriculture and a lot of people know me
but a again very good question I called
some people at the California
Cattlemen's Association and it took me
nearly full ten minutes from for them
for them to just give me some very
simple statistics for them to find out
who I was you know and I wasn't going to
use them those statistics against them
you know um so that that makes it tough
for for what I do so so
are there certain things that you do to
build trust I'm using you come in and
you don't really want to get to know too
much about them and we know that from
from doing our show like we would meet
people in the lobby and it would be
great we want to talk we'd almost be
like you know what we almost don't want
to go there because we wanted to be
fresh for the air so we're trying to
limit the small talk and and and limit
hey where'd you grow up kind of a thing
for a little bit other things that you
would do just little tactics not chat
tactics but just rules that you would
use yeah you know there's there's one
general rule that i use in in in
documentary and and you know the
documentaries that i make our are not
super controversial they certainly tell
a side of the story you know you're a
limited time like it's difficult to
explore all of the facets of you know of
one particular story but really the
point i'm trying to get across in and
out in the documentaries that I make is
hey this is this story um so one of my
general rules is um I never take the
Michael Moore approach which means um I
will never try to edit in such a way or
put out material that I think maybe that
that I think may cause somebody harm
down the road I think there's a there's
a trust thing involved um and then on
top of that you just got to be honest
with people it is what it is the first
thing I have people do when I meet them
is sign a release form and you don't
know how many times we call them we call
them re-- rides re-ride stories how many
times these Cowboys that we get to sit
down with you know they put their hand
up and they say you have this off now
right and I'm like okay I have to turn
this off because I know you're about to
tell me a story that when you're dead I
want to share with people you know and
it that's one of the most difficult
things that I faced to convince those
guys know I'm not turning this camera
off you know that the reason we're
sitting down with you is because I want
to hear these real stories about you
know um you know around here
um there's a famous rancher and Phil
stadler a Hall of Famer uh one of the
first Cowboys in in in all of the United
States to bring cattle in from Mexico
from for breeding so the cattle you see
when you're driving from where I'm at
from San Francisco to Yosemite and
Carrie you're familiar with that drive
but when you're when you're coming this
way those cattle are direct descendants
from the the cattle that Phil stadler
had had brought in from Mexico
everybody's gotta fill stadler story or
a day vermont story or you know what all
of these names that i have over time
become familiar with but they all say um
you know turn the camera off and i'll
tell you this story and it's like I know
I don't want you to do that not that's
the reason we're here I'm trying to
collect this and you know uh it's one
thing as a documentarian or a historian
to collect that information and keep it
and hoard it you know yeah yes we've got
it we're going to put it in your
archives it's a whole other thing and I
think we're living in this day and age
it's a whole other thing to put it out
there and you know like what you guys
did with goodbye promise is a great
example you Yuri have the opportunity to
put it in people's face you know if I
can create a cut that'll give somebody
you know a collector attention span in
three and a half minutes about this
great story even though they may not
know these Cowboys but give them a
three-and-a-half minute cut of us great
story that they'll never forget on
YouTube um well now I have the
opportunity to to you know expose them
to a completely different culture and
that's what it is i mean the western
lifestyle and where i'm at it's a it's a
culture of life that i think a lot of
people take for granted one more
question slightly off topic what do you
do when the the person that you're
interviewing is just being really nice
about everything and oh it was great it
everybody was so wonderful and you can
sense intuitively that's not the truth
and that's not the real story and you're
trying to dig deeper and you don't want
to antagonize them and you don't want to
be a sort of gotcha journalist but you
want to get them beyond that nice point
where everything is just fluffy and
wonderful and you realize that's not the
real truth um
you know that's interesting um I think
the approach that I've taken in the past
is to take what they say for face value
and then find somebody else who's gonna
tell me the truth um you know I can't
make somebody tell me what they don't
want to say I mean I I don't have a lie
detector attached to them you know um I
have been in those situations um where I
know the story um and I will try to
multiple times you know in the
questioning be more specific or you know
try to invoke what I think the truth may
be from what I heard I'm out of them but
if they're not going to tell you they're
not going to tell you and I think I just
I you know i chalk it up to of course i
keep the footage but i chalk it up to
you know that's that must be their
perspective on it and i look for
somebody else if that's what I'm looking
for um I look for somebody else who's
going to tell me the truth and believe
me there's there's a lot of straight
shooting Cowboys around here that we're
are willing to tell you the truth mm-hmm
so you just kind of move on you realize
you're not gonna be able to or with that
person why waste the time so you know
one thing I wanted to touch on here
kevin is here you are you have your work
you said you know thankfully you know
you have funding for a lot of work that
you do food it sounds like you have an
arsenal of short films you also have
this feature film and it sounds like you
know even though the work is funded you
know here you are you are still trying
to find your own distribution path for
the short films and for the feature film
can you talk about the difference in
distributing both you know the short
films and the feature film can we just
start with their starter yeah i do want
to point out that when i say that
they're funded they're not funded
heavily um if it's nonprofit and on the
average for instance um you know my film
changing the game shameless plug here
but my film changing the game this film
cost um three thousand dollars to make
um and we ate top ramen and we stayed at
people's
is when we had to travel to you know San
Luis and and Santa Barbara to in order
to collect interviews we you know we
begged friends just like any other you
know indie filmmaker would do um what a
lot of people don't understand in order
to make that film we had to spend twenty
seven hundred dollars on a camera so
that compel that greatly diminishes your
budget so they're not funded heavily um
in the again you're the other part of
your question was distribution um have a
very niche audience um I know that you
know trying to distribute and connect
with him an audience the way that you
guys did with um goodbye promise just
kind of randomly you know hey this is my
film check it out is not effective for
me so um I also have to understand my
audience in terms of as I mentioned
earlier a lot of the rodeo and ranching
crowd are not heavily involved in social
networking fortunately you know for the
advocates of magic agriculture that is
evolving in and they're they're starting
to get more involved so they're becoming
more connected um but you know I had to
do a couple of print advertising deals
which were kind of a kind of a swap a
little bit um was one of the things that
I did with changing the game was I went
to a magazine called Roper sports news
which is specifically targeted at team
ropers which is the genre the film on
and I said um if you let me put my um um
let me put my VOD on your site give me a
page I'll write an article let me put it
on your site I'll make you a sponsor and
whenever I tell people go to the site
and watch it I'll say brought to you by
Roper sports news that has been a great
marriage I mean that has been a huge
thing for me a lot of people discovered
the film you know the film their
digitally um ultimately distribution
came down to DVDs again in my genre
people want something tangible they want
to hold it in their hands um they are
ranchers and team ropers they you know
they don't use the HTC one or the iphone
5 they want the flip phone because they
put it in their pocket they fold it up
put in their pocket because they're
working all the time and it doesn't but
dial anybody um so it's a little bit
different you know they're a little bit
technologically challenged but I'm
forced to use technology in order to
connect with them so it was kind of a
cross between both as far as selling the
film um and Lucas I think wrote an
article about this in filmmaker magazine
when he was here um uh as far as selling
the film I went to DVD I put it on my my
website I took it for the first time to
Ruby mountain film festival in Elko
which is an awesome film festival if you
ever have the chance to go it's awesome
film festival great people um and that
was sort of the first laurels that I got
on the cover um and a couple of magazine
articles some key people Bobby cook at
western horseman of course Roper sports
news some other people wrote some stuff
about it and it took off like that um
but again my genre doesn't necessarily
read blogs they want the hard copy
magazine and so I knew print advertising
was going to be invaluable when Lucas
was here one of the parts that he was
writing about in his article that he
wrote about me was it was pretty
astonished that every time I went to my
computer and turn my computer there be
four or five orders for a DVD um I said
it cost 3,000 to make I'm pretty sure in
the end it's grossed probably five or
six thousand dollars in DVD sales so if
you in d terms you put it that way you
know it's a success so I've made back
what I put into it and you know in all
the cost thereof so um it's not it's not
paying my rent you know but at least I'm
getting my art out there so that's
really cool and and and what do you do
to sort of keep the life of the film
going or keep eyeballs on and sort of
keep those sales going you know that's
another great question and i took a jade
applause approach on that and a kevin
gant approach on that i love how we all
work with each other you
no Jay made this great movie on that I
through many at and i just love kevin's
music um inspires me constantly um and
kevin was able to take that and then
forward his own career so what I did was
um um I got with my subjects and I said
now how can I help you you guys let me
make this movie and you're letting me
take all the royalties from this movie
so what can I do to help you so now I'm
involved with helping them break through
that technology challenge and I'm able
to share with them my knowledge of
social networking and how to reach
another audience course of course these
guys are retired and how they make money
is through teaching other people to do
what they did through roping schools in
rodeo schools and so um I've helped them
set up sort of Facebook pages and where
I'm helping them consult what how how to
reach out to people on their website
we've done print advertising for them
and that's what is so so it's become
this sort of trade they gave me this
great product and all these great
stories and they're letting me profit on
that so I went to them and I said you
know what can I do and they said this is
what I need and I said this is how I can
help you with that and um we're seeing
success in that as a matter of fact uh
looks like i'll be taking over their
website um pretty soon in order to to
you know kind of real job rebrand them i
guess um you know they're they're not
dead is what i'm trying to say even
though they're retired and they roped in
the 60s and you know 90s the last buckle
when i guess uh world title was a 85 i
believe might even been 97 i'd have to
do my research again but they're not
dead a lot of people think they are as a
matter of fact recently the rumor float
around Facebook that leo is dead it was
like quickly aliquots alive and kicking
in arizona and he's still winning money
so and so I mean have you has this led
to in addition to that has this led to
sort of like maybe some smaller side
film projects you know cuz it almost
sounds you can use those you know
sort of tutorial or video or something
as another way to shine light on what
they're doing now as well as maybe an
ancillary way to sort of shine am i back
to changing changing the game you know
it has a lot of people have you know in
and everything that I do it's very niche
genre on the western lifestyle on dale
jackson who is a local author around
here just won the will rogers medallion
award for his book they rode good horses
um which is that's pretty prestigious I
mean the Will Rogers medallion is for
western author is as just about as good
as it gets um and he reached out to me
and now he's wanting me to collaborate
with him on doing some book trailers and
some things that you know he has going
on so you know with what I've done here
it opens a whole new door into a whole
set of western authors incidentally um
they rode good horses has already been
bought for a movie script the deal is
done they're gonna make a Hollywood
production out of it um so you know
hopefully maybe one of these days I'll
actually be able to come down and visit
you guys and I'll be in LA and um you
know working on a real crooks oh well
you know you'll have to take us
horseback riding and I've you have ever
been written the worst here I have at
the equestrian center in Burbank at one
time it was a lot of fun I was scared
but I mean it's your urine sort of in
control this huge animal and it's it's
it's very power I've heard that they've
used um sometimes horseback riding the
treat people with different problems and
therapy that because you're in control
of this huge animal you're able to sort
of transcend other things that are wrong
and but that wasn't why I was there but
I was there with some friends but it was
a lot of fun thank you Mike yeah I've
never done it so you know maybe that'll
make for a special Elliot game I'm there
Kevin excellent well I wanna again i'ma
I'm a big advocate so I want it I want
to dispel a myth that Karen just said
we've got it you're not in charge of
that animal he has a mind of his own
and um you you have a whole lot of trust
on the back of that animal that he's
gonna do what he does and incidentally
Burbank equestrian center that's where
William Shatner right so um yeah yeah I
don't know much about it I know there's
a lot of people at horses sort of near
where we are and and still sometimes see
them not so went to the neighborhood but
in the trails where actually goodbye
promise was shot huh oh yeah I didn't I
I don't know much about whether I know
for me it was scary I was very scared
and there was this feeling of being
vulnerable in some sense because you
don't know what that animals going to do
and in passing them around sort of
further up the road you know just
driving you know just really slow by
them and you don't know are you can
scare them and so it's it's kind of you
hear that that's an incredibly powerful
metaphor carrying um because you know
comes back to goodbye promise there's a
lot of trust there you don't know what's
going to happen in and it's an animal
you have no control over so really
interesting metaphor you just used well
um this has been a great chat for us
Kevin you know it you know this has been
you know it's been sort of several years
in the making I'm leading up to this
point and we're really thrilled that we
had a chance to sit down with you on a
Sunday afternoon and catch up with you
through this google hangout method and
and and here so move your inside in
terms of what we've done and to get take
it into sort of the cowboy realm which
is we haven't had we have it at least
for me I haven't had a lot of exposure
to this world so this has been really
fascinating work thrilled that you've
been a great supporter of what we do
still think yeah yeah I always I always
am and in indie film community in
general I do I you know in closing I
want to say if you guys want more of the
end I'm always in pitch mode if you want
more of the cowboy thing come up here
and make movies I mean we're right here
at UH Tuolumne County is just east of me
and they have over 300 films to their
credit the Lone Ranger parts of
Eastwood's Unforgiven was filmed here on
a ranch that I've shot at many times the
grown ranch um they just
oodles irnos the Great Train Robbery I
mean it's just so many films and there's
so many resources and quality crew up
here and casting directors and people
willing to work so you know if you're
those that are watching if you're an
independent filmmaker and you're looking
for a place to shoot come on up explore
a little bit um it's real film film
friendly around here kind of an expanded
I mean how hard is it to tap into those
resources what do people have to do I
mean is there is there a contact person
out how would one get started i'm gerry
day at the Tuolumne County film film
commission is it be your first start um
if you want anything else anyone know
who you want references contact me I'll
tell you who to I'll put you right in
touch with anybody you want to talk you
know to get things done or at least to
move forward I mean I don't want to take
control of anybody's film but you know
one of the one of the challenges that I
deal with as a filmmaker where I'm out
outside of Hollywood is is having um
people to work with in order to you know
to make the film so you know we'd like
to see more of you guys come out our way
leave LA you know go ahead and fulfill
your goodbyes promise and come out where
we're at and um you know you can you can
follow your dream here too and you can
do it anywhere you can do it Michigan
you can do from there Jersey you can do
it you can do it anywhere I'm not
convinced these days that we need
Hollywood to follow our dreams and this
this chat is a fine example I mean we're
also connected nowadays and the world
continues to get smaller and we need to
explore more of it so